What if all the oceans disappeared
from the Earth surface?
What would a world with
no high seas look like?
What would happen to all the
creatures that live underwater?
Could humanity survive on the planet
if there were no options left?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
all the earth's oceans and factory
in the early years of our planet,
the earth was flat,
but not in a way you might think the
earth just didn't have any mountains and
was mostly covered with water.
Then about a billion years ago,
land emerged from under the seat
and change the planet's atmosphere.
This led to the debut of the first
life forms here on earth. Eventually,
the planet will heat up and
all the oceans will vanish.
This isn't scheduled to happen
for another billion years,
but how bad would it be if all
the oceans evaporated? Right now
today, oceans cover about
70% of the earth's surface.
If you put all that water into
Olympic sized swimming pools,
you'd need over 500 trillion of them.
With all the oceans gone,
we'd still have some water available.
Oceans account for 97% of
all the water on the planet.
The remaining 3% is held in
rivers, lakes, underground water,
even the ice caps,
but that wouldn't be enough to
make up for the loss of the oceans.
The world's oceans act as a
global climate control system.
They absorb most of the sun's heat and
distributed evenly around the planet so
that no one area it gets
too hot or too cold.
They also sustain the water
cycle evaporating into
clouds and then reigning back
to Earth,
but you won't need to keep your
umbrella at hand expecting a big storm.
Once all the oceans
evaporated in our scenario,
the earth wouldn't be able to keep
all that vapor in the atmosphere.
Oceans would leave our planet for good,
turning it into a vast scorching desert.
Okay.
Sea creatures would be the obvious first
casualties in these conditions then
with no oceans to absorb
the heat from the sun,
the earth would slowly roast
until it turned into Venus.
How long would we have until our
planet became uninhabitable? Well,
whatever water was left would
evaporate in a matter of days,
leaving humanity to die from dehydration.
Most animals would go extinct
without water. Who knows?
Maybe camels would become earth's
next civilization. After a few days,
plants would give up their attempts to
survive without water. After a few weeks,
the same would happen to our forests.
Eventually they'd catch fire and
would keep burning until there was no
vegetation left.
In about a year's time,
the earth would turn into
a burnt and lifeless rock,
and without it, probably wouldn't get
the chance to produce life ever again.
Maybe one day,
another life form might visit our solar
system and wonder what happened to our
once glorious planet,
but that's a story for another.
What if.